so back for number two yeah so how do
you get into character as a dog like
what do you do when you're going through
this recording sessions well I have a
dog okay usually it's right there I
always just pet my dog before he leaves
like rub off on me give me you but
really it's all its grip generated you
know you walk in and you see what you're
gonna do and then you just put yourself
and that knee and you don't really think
of it as though that you're playing a
dog it's just to try to bring truth and
honesty to the character and forget you
know it's like let the animation and the
notion of Rhett descriptives do the work
for you and just be as honest as you can
with what you're saying yeah a little
bit different this time around cuz you
have a different voice partner yes you
called me yeah yeah so Louie was there
any difference in that in terms like you
know yeah I don't record together right
yeah no I mean the first time I saw
Patton was here like a man it really is
but it's it's it's really really for the
audience you know when you when you go
to when people go to the movies
actors are typically you know the ones
that are like associated with the movie
right with animation and now having been
on the inside of like a major animated
movie I can't stress enough how much the
editors the colourists the animators the
director really aren't responsible for
what a good time you're having right
we're in there and we're recording it
but they are the ones that put it all
together and make you enjoy it yeah for
sure yeah it's a well put now another
person is the Mississippi that blows my
mind
Harrison Ford yeah pretty cool yeah so
what's the reaction when you hear well I
heard in the booth I was going in to
record you know for Duke one day and
Brian the writer and Chris the director
were there like well we got some kind of
cool news it's not out yet but Harrison
Ford's gonna be in the movie like it's
incredible I mean you know look I don't
need to tell anybody watching what an
icon Harrison Ford is and for someone my
age 30 no 47 like what a childhood hero
you know his Empire Strikes Back in Star
Wars obviously it goes without saying
but everything he's ever done
just to be this you know and in the
Kevin Bacon what's the game Kevin Bacon
yeah one degree now well that's
something like that day we're here that
news does that change things a little
bit like to get a little bit like oh no
well you know no no the fact that it's
his first movie his first animated movie
and that he chose this cuz I'm betting
other people have asked him to do right
animated movies before and for him to do
this is a testament to Chris Mela Dondre
and illumination and this and the you
know the top-shelf quality of the movies
that they do so the fact that he jumped
in on this means a tremendous amount and
he plays such a cool character I think
people are gonna be very very very
excited and completely you know just
thrust back into their seat and be like
yeah that's that's what I want from
Harris afford exactly now I've seen
every single episode of modern fare you
have I looked it up was 232 episodes you
guys have done yep so we're going into
the final season I know what this season
value got to do the Lion King yeah the
Simba child thing with Halley's twins
what do you hope for the final season
like confusable comeback I think Fizbo
you have to come back I mean I think
I'll probably demand at some point at
least a quality reference or flashback
cuz its to ease too close to my heart
but you know I don't I don't really know
I do have any hopes for Cameron Mitchell
by the end of it like it's like a child
again we're gonna Rufus at that you know
I do have hopes yeah but I can't say
what they are because I think there's a
decent chance my hopes will be true okay
so and you know it's just the idea of
Mitch and cam living on you know well
past the show being over you know and
when when we finished that final episode
for the audience that have come to love
us to know that we're living a
completely maybe new different fulfilled
life okay okay that's nice to use on
yeah
you